you continue to do your movies you also
have the show which I love I love
listening to the thoughts that you all
have and y'all had some opinions about
things have been going on especially
with one Mr Kanye West we have got to
counsel him and I know we do not try to
be in a council culture but we've got to
hit him in his pockets now because he
obviously does not care about the
African-American culture what how do we
move forward from there well we've been
trying to move forward with love and
with prayer and we've literally been
finding out that
that isn't working so I thought maybe a
little extra tough love in there that
maybe that's what Kanye is missing I
believe more anything else he's missing
his mother somebody that would say now
boy you don't went too far and that's
when I said that Kanye is a wonderful
artist and I just hate to see his legacy
tarnish with this the Outburst but Kanye
if I can say this to you my brother if
you need help don't be afraid to go get
it please do because it's just don't
ruin your legacy like this you have four
beautiful children that don't need to
see Daddy's Legacy
absolutely destroyed like this
foreign
what
what one must show up and show out
you're showing out it says where will
our Gala so I'm doing the wearable art
tell me about this wearable art my gosh
I'm so glad that everyone dressed up for
the theme we are celebrating the Glory
Days of Harlem Nights and I I'm seeing
look bling it's a star-studded red
carpet I think everyone has missed this
event you know not happening because of
covet and we're back and we're showing
up honey
what Miss Teen is doing I mean her
daughter maybe the greatest entertainer
of all time but
that's true too great but look at what
she is doing in this community where she
just joined this community not that long
I know just came to LA and her and
Richard together what they're giving
back to the future generation next
because that's what they're missing in
school nowadays remember we had art we
had music we had the instruments all of
that has been taken away the Arts have
been stripped so I'm so proud of Tina
that she's bringing back the Arts from
painting singing I just love this and
you know because she could just go and
be cool and be Beyonce is Solange Mama
nope she out there still looking good
foreign